[Música]
ahora sí con luces con sonido y con toda
la información económica llega a nuestro
compañero jorge hurtado al estudio de
france 24 jorge bienvenido iniciamos
hablando de rusia porque el kremlin ya
empezó a cumplir su promesa de cortar el
suministro de gas si no se pagan rublos
y los primeros afectados son bulgaria y
polonia ahora que se vence en estos
plazos los gobiernos de toda europa
tienen que decidir si aceptan las
condiciones de putin de pagar en la
moneda rusa o pierden suministros
cruciales y se enfrentan a un razón el
racionamiento energético solo en
bulgaria el 90% del hidrocarburo que
consume viene de rusia mientras polonia
recibe al menos la mitad de su gas
importado de rusia los precios del gas
en europa subieron un 17% ya que los
operadores miden el riesgo de que otros
países europeos se vean afectados en los
próximos meses según las autoridades
polacas estaban preparadas para este
momento con la diversificación de sus
suministros de gas las reservas de gas
están ahí en el 76 por ciento de su
capacidad según las autoridades pero
alemania y austria han dicho que no
están preparados para poner fin a esta
dependencia del gas ruso mientras la
comisión europea a todos sus miembros a
recortar en al menos dos tercios la
importación de gas y petróleo rusos este
año que ha quedado aclara la
interdependencia de los combustibles
rusos con esta guerra pasamos ahora
hablar de ucrania y las consecuencias
que ha tenido este conflicto en américa
latina' valentina preparamos una serie
que emitiremos en el transcurso de esta
semana para ver algunos casos
específicos de países que están siendo
afectados o que están sintiendo este
efecto de la invasión en los bolsillos
de las empresas y de los ciudadanos
comenzamos un ecuador cuyos enormes
envíos de banano a rusia cayeron
drásticamente nuestro corresponsal
gustavo ortega visitó una plantación y
nos cuenta la historia
ecuador es el mayor productor de banano
del mundo
el país exporta 4 de cada 10 bananos
según cifras del banco central pero la
guerra entre rusia y ucrania amenaza el
negocio de los productores como franklin
torres la semana 9 que fue cuando se
produjo la guerra
tuvimos precios de 6 dólares 625 que es
el precio oficial de la caja de banano
el precio de la semana 10 bajó el 50 por
ciento el precio de la caja de banano
y hoy estamos vendiendo al 25% de la
caja
la reducción del valor del producto
también preocupa los recolectores martín
garcía dedicada hace 30 años a las cimas
del banano siente amenazada su
estabilidad laboral en es por el banano
genera 300 mil empleos directos y un
millón indirectos que hasta están
reduciendo personal porque no hay dinero
para cancelar no ya desde ya hay
problemas no nos cancelan por el
problema del banano porque no hay dinero
de tema
rusia ha sido un mercado estratégico
para el banano ecuatoriano en los
últimos 15 años según cifras de la
asociación de comercialización y
exportación de banano del ecuador de
2021 con corte a octubre uno de cada
diez bananos se exportó a rusia mientras
que la unión europea se destinó poco más
del 27 por ciento del total en su orden
otros grandes consumidores fueron el
medio oriente eeuu y europa del este
entre otros
de vuelta a los cultivos 585.000 cajas
de banano no pudieron salir de ecuador
desde febrero 2022 por falta de otros
mercados la devaluación del rublo ha
encarecido la exportación del banano y
la falta de pagos obliga a franklin a
buscar soluciones con un descuento a
nuestras liquidaciones de banano como se
lo hace el impuesto para que eso sirva
para este fondo de contingencia y con
ese fondo de contingencia poder de
alguna forma financiar lo que nosotros
queremos hacer el sector bananero
intenta buscar soluciones rápidas a esta
crisis simple vista para ello de mal
mente el gobierno y que las reglas de
exportación del banano crear los
registros de hectáreas sembradas en el
país según ellos inexistentes y
controlar la competencia desde al que
abarata los precios en medio del
conflicto
jorge finalizamos con los indicadores
económicos de la jornada empezamos en
walls el que cerró con fuertes pérdidas
en una muy mala jornada por las
tecnológicas a la espera que varios
gigantes del sector presenten sus
cuentas trimestrales en europa el dax 40
de frankfurt cerró con una bajada del
120 por ciento la tercera consecutiva-
arrastrado por las caídas en wall street
sobre todo por los valores tecnológicos
que mencionamos antes en américa latina'
el índice de precios y cotizaciones de
la bolsa mexicana de valores registró
este martes una caída del 0,36 por
ciento como efecto contagio por los
descensos en las principales bolsas
mundiales porque usted muchas gracias
por esta ampliación ya continuamos aquí
en directo de américa con el espacio con
nuestros corresponsales
[Música]